and welcome to fox news primetime i'm
maria bartiromo
tonight loaded words from the chinese
communist party in the first
face-to-face u.s china meeting in alaska
the u.s attempted to hold the ccp
accountable for its genocide of ethnic
minorities
with secretary of state anthony blinken
raising the atrocities happening in
xinjiang
more than one million ethnic minorities
locked up in camps
getting quote re-educated but the ccp
and the state
run media tried to shame the united
states
by calling out the us's supposed racism
of black lives matter and its movement
why should the ccp get lectured by the
americans
we're teaching our eighth graders
critical race theory we are fighting
amongst ourselves constantly calling
each other racists or worse
words matter words from the progressive
woke
left are reverberating across the world
and hurting the us's standing as the
freest
fairest and strongest superpower of the
world
as i have said many times it is not
enough to denounce the ccp as bad
it is not enough to point out the
decades of intellectual property theft
the genocide on its people it is not
enough to denounce the authoritarian
control the ccp yields in hong kong
in taiwan and its attempts to do the
same across the world
no you have to actually believe that the
free world is superior to the communists
you have to believe this system lifts
people from poverty
and creates an american dream never seen
before
but how can you how can you say the free
world is superior
when you are constantly talking about
systemic racism
and how bad america is when you are
assuming our seventh and eighth graders
are born racist
and need to identify as a human not as
mom and dad
not as he or she not as white or black
how can you truly justify this system is
superior
the ccp is following all of our
political debates very closely
and they are using this propaganda to
divide us
the biden administration and the
progressives in congress
should know that my parents lived the
american dream
my grandfather carmine bartoromo came to
this country in 1906
with 12 dollars in his pocket my
mother's grandfather giuseppe moriale
came
years earlier in 1896 also with just a
few dollars in his pocket
what courage it must have taken for both
for carmine to leave family and friends
that he knew so well
in nuchara naples and for giuseppe to do
the same
to leave all behind that they built in
santa margarita de belichi in agrigento
sicily
to get on a boat and travel for days
with only the hope of opportunity in
america for the next generation
they did it the legal way they waited
their turn
they weren't allowed to jump the line
they went through the naturalization
process
as one million legal immigrants do every
year here in america
when they arrive the first thing they
did is fight for this great country
in world war one then they came home and
they settled
in brooklyn new york my grandfather
carmine traveled back and forth to italy
on a ship called the rex
then he and his cousin being bricklayers
in italy
built a restaurant in brooklyn with
their bare hands
they named it the rex manor after that
ship
my family owned the rex for 50 years my
entire family worked at the rex my dad
took it over after he served our country
years later
and i became the co-check girl at the
rex manor
that was my very first job i learned
first
hand what it means to work hard what it
means to earn it
to love this country and yell it from
the rooftops
america is the greatest country in the
world our freedom
our liberties are unmatched we cannot
take them for granted
it is the reason our young people go and
risk sometimes lose their lives
in battlefields across the world we need
to thank them
and we need to celebrate this greatness
of america stand
tall and protecting it sure we make
mistakes
and we must continue to get better but
we are not
a systemic racist country we are the
best system in the world
know it unfortunately not enough of us
are yelling it from the rooftops
our adversaries know that we are faced
with a serious
adversary in communist china that wants
to overtake this greatness
words matter and the chinese communist
party is using those words
against us the progressives in congress
need to start
understanding this before the chinese
empire
gets any stronger